desperate to broaden its appeal from its
traditional white guy base the National
Hockey League has been forced to
backtrack over an added posted For an
upcoming Florida job fair after Governor
Ron desantis's office slammed the ad as
discriminatory in the now deleted Help
Wanted post the organizers required
participants in the fair to be either
female a minority
lgbtqia plus a person with disability or
a veteran that's it straight white men
who didn't serve in the military need
not apply desantis's team blasting the
job fair event quote NHL you are
officially on notice about your planned
events in Florida unlawful
discrimination will not be tolerated it
kind of reminds the judge of the Irish
need not applied days in the 19th
century yeah isn't it interesting how
with the woke we keep going backwards
yeah you know that it's that is a
backward trajectory that the woke want
to bring us to which I think is the
takedown of this country tree you know
get rid of everything get rid of the
statues get rid of the you know the the
concepts the fundamentals like Law and
Order and uh you know all white men
you're worthless and you're a
supremacist but the thing about this is
that uh one of the things I wanted to
address is the word Aloha they said that
in that word Aloha that we shouldn't use
it because we don't really know the
meaning of the word Aloha which I always
thought was hello and they're saying no
it signals more and you are
appropriating if you use that word I
mean how crazy is this it's like hello
and love and all the good stuff all in
one word but they don't want you to use
it yeah they don't want you to use it
now I used to swear in newly naturalized
citizens like 300 people at a time and
it was the happiest day of their lives
and there would be Indians and there
would be Spanish and French and
Egyptians and I would say hello in like
10 different languages as part of
including everyone right not trying to
exclude him it's crazy
well I don't know I'm a Whitey I don't
know I think they should open this up to
include the hockey actual players oh the
hockey players yeah I mean it's like
it's like why are they just limited
office jobs and executive operations I
think that all those people that you
mentioned should be eligible to play
hockey and if you don't do that you're
you're a bunch of racists my daughter
told me the other day Joey that uh that
you can no longer talking real estate
you can no longer say master bedroom
right yeah yeah did you hear that before
yes I never heard it before I've never
owned a house big enough to have one
that said that says a lot that's do you
ever work in a field can't say that you
can't say it anymore Fields but real
quick all this Hey listen their response
to this was oh wanted to Target
audiences that may not be that familiar
with hockey let me tell you there are a
lot of straight white dudes down in the
South that don't know anything about
hockey and while we appreciate the idea
of seeing some Canadians and Russians
fighting American cities every now and
then we don't know much about the sport
but you'd be surprised at the redneck
Ingenuity we could bring to the table if
you weren't excluding us for being
straight white male and you know not
knowing much about your sport and on
this USA Today thing about words right
I'm all about it listen I better not
hear y'all say y'all again if you're not
from below the Mason-Dixon or west of
Louisiana Texans hear me out uh don't
say y'all again because that's our
culture that's who we are to us Jeff
Foxworthy is a is a poet not some not
some stand-up comic Sideshow like you
treat him you better get my words out
your mouth okay you hear me all right
come on okay Will Smith uh you know Dana
it's clumsy but doesn't hockey have to
broaden its appeal well I don't know
what the NHL press office was doing but
did they make it's the whole Disney
Florida Rhonda Santos debacle I mean
DeSantis wins and he has made a promise
and he's making good on the promise he
said Florida is where wokeness goes to
die and he's making good on that this
also reminds me of that group I've
mentioned before it's called Do no harm
it is where this making sure that
medical professionals are not basically
having this happen to them they get
anonymous tips from people in the
profession saying well this job
application just or job opening just
went up and it says that basically no
Asians need apply that's not allowed so
Do no harm we'll call them call the
state call as their lawyers and say you
have to take it down and they often will
win but they'll go to court for it and
that's what you need people like that or
people like DeSantis and others who are
saying enough of this here's the
surprising thing about that I guarantee
you when those people are contacted
whether it's the NHL or not or any other
organization are surprised to hear that
it's illegal they're like wait you can't
say let's go say Canadian say you want
black people you can't say you want
handicapped people
is trying to be fair they are probably
they have no idea it's discrimination
quickly DeSantis wins what wins what
wins he wins
he gets the props from this oh yeah yeah
absolutely all right definitely free
money hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade why
don't you do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now